but we have a special guest with us a
good friend of ours is live from spain
making us all jealous as usual
grandmaster maurice ashley is joining
the fray maurice tell us how is madrid
well if i tell you you're going to get
upset
i'm already upset it's okay
madrid is fantastic the energy here is
absolutely extraordinary uh
it's just an incredible buzz in the city
and the tournament itself i mean
everybody here is excited about it and
this after all it's a candidate so what
can you
what more can you ask for
maurice i've seen photos of the palace
that these guys are playing in it just
looks awesome that's got to be one of
the nicest buildings i've ever seen for
a chess tournament
the palace is uh palatial
[Laughter]
it's incredible i was actually trying to
film from one of the halls so that you
guys would see better backdrop than the
one i've given you right now but the
audio was crazy it was just echoing off
these giants marble walls and
and but it's it's incredible it's you
remember
but you also remember it was a
spectacular venue oh it was one of our
favorite venues because of the way it
looked and
it was the old town hall of the city but
this one is just like
yeah different i'm not gonna say it puts
i'm gonna say it puts love into shame
because you know we got friends in
louisville
but wink wink it's pretty damn good
right maurice como estas uh
i wanted to ask you tell us a bit about
the energy of the players you're there
you can feel them who has the most
positive energy in your opinion
the confidence i'm seeing that fabiano
exudes is extraordinary i mean he looks
like the guy who's like i've been here
done this i'm trying to get back people
are talking about alareza you know
pumping up other possible names ding
loren who was my pick
to do really well here i gladly i didn't
have to pick the way tom forces us to
pick and you know after the first round
i would have said oh no i'm not going to
pick ding anymore
but fabi is definitely looking like he's
here on a mission and i think he's
playing really well right now
um any insights uh about the players
seconds uh we were very happy to see
lubamir lavoyevich a black name from the
past as he arrived with richard rapport
any any other players seconds hanging
out or is it all rather hidden
i haven't seen anyone frankly and i
should say i'm a tourist here i'm not
working you know i'm just hanging out i
haven't gotten the chance to be a chess
tourist at these events usually
you're setting up and getting ready for
work right uh so i've only seen
churchill fabies a second i haven't seen
anyone else it looks like they're all
staying hush-hush and pretty quiet but
again i'm i'm not allowed into the
player's room uh okay i get the vip
treatment but still it's like now
you can't go in there you can't go in
there so i i don't i haven't had any
insights into those players into the
seconds and how is the ambiance for the
spectator is it a spectator friendly
event how what's happening outside of
the hall when the tournament is done
absolutely very spectator friendly they
do have this setup where you have
commentators you have the spanish
language commentators giving the very
lively commentating
for the spanish-speaking crowd nothing
for the english-speaking crowd after all
we're in madrid but
people are just buzzing around they even
have a fan zone because
the tickets are limited so they have to
have a special area off-site for fans to
go that's more boisterous so it's
definitely an event that the chess fans
here are
mouth-watering for them they're just
super excited and after all it's such a
huge event for the chess world that
we're all excited to see this happen
maurice you said you're there as a fan
uh where are you now located where are
you coming from to madrid
well i live in fort lauderdale florida
as you guys know i moved there i had to
go to new york for a special ceremony in
new york so i went there first hung out
with my peeps and then left
to directly from jfk to come here to
madrid my trip will keep me here i do
have one big event tomorrow for a chest
and a tea group immortal game that i've
signed with
and then from then i'm going to hang out
a few more days in madrid and then i'm
going to be off to the south of france
where my father and now my son also live
so i'll be in france for a couple of
weeks and then i'm going to come back to
barcelona for a little bit and then
madrid and then i'm back in the usa
you're a busy man terrible terrible
i i hope we can cope with this tough
summer ahead of you maurice
yeah nice it's good to see that you're
keeping busy and you sure look uh you
look very well my friend
thank you thank you and i do miss st
louis i do miss all of you we miss you
we miss you here commentary with us here
are some of the shots of the palace that
maurice has been talking about as he
explains it's just so spectacular in the
inside of the building
it's gilded
gold everywhere marble and the most
beautiful
paintings walls incredible you know
everything everything inside is is an
instant postcard it looks gorgeous
and so is everything outside madrid is
gorgeous as a city this is a great place
to walk around people tourists are
everywhere taking photos selfies it's
just an extraordinary place so
you don't get to be a fan too much of
these events when we're working and
we're stuck inside for hours and hoping
to make some time
i've this is my first candidate as well
even attend so yeah i know yeah so
you're like dude you're not a rookie
what's wrong with you your first
candidate
i can't believe that that's remarkable
right you never got a chance to visit
the candidates before this event he was
always working here no
maurice uh we've been doing predictions
as you know and some of them are better
than others at doing predictions i'm not
going to name any names now give us your
prediction maurice
like i said i would have said ding lyran
i thought he was hungry
the hungriest maybe because of his
horrible result especially from the last
event
his start was really poor though and
so you're asking me to predict after
round three my second favorite was fabi
so i'm going to have to go with fabi
especially after seeing the way he's
playing at the moment he just looks like
he's really informed i really would love
to see alareza pull it off frankly it
just the youngin just turned 19. he the
talk of the chess world uh the next
big dog in the in our game but
he looks he looks unstable his end games
are looking kind of funny he did get
fortunate in the first two games if he
can pull this one off against nakamura
he'll be back in the hunt for sure
but
fabi looks like
the vet that really wants to get it done
maurice thank you so much for taking
time and joining us we really appreciate
you and we miss you uh but enjoy your
summer sounds like it's going to be a
spectacular one
thanks guys keep doing the great work
all righty oh thank you maurice and yeah
that is great to have insights live from
spain of course what a great playing
hall they have it really is it really